[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du Grand jité des
territoires voici tout de suite les
titres de l'actualité comment faire face
à la hausse continue et généraliser des
prix poussés par un pouvoir d'achat en
berne les Français s'adaptent et
changent leurs habitudes de consommation
comme nous le montrera la rédaction de
TV7 la chaîne du groupe sud-ouest dès le
début de ce journal ils ont décidé de
vivre l'aventure en roulant dans l'Aube
Canal 32 nous racontera le projet
étonnant d'une famille qui délaisse sa
maison pour vivre dans un quart aménager
un défi encore en chantier à découvrir
dans quelques instants et puis
impossible de ne pas évoquer cette
semaine la Coupe du monde de rugby
ouverrez grâce à nos partenaires de la
Dépêche du Midi et de TL7 dans la Loire
que la passion de l'ovali serit partout
sur le territoire et puis en fin de
journal vous découvrirez la culture amè
indienne grâce à l'action de passionnés
qui ont vécu le temps d'un weekend comme
à l'époque du Far West dans et coutumes
traditionnelles nous feront voyager dans
le temps voilà maison débute donc ce
journal avec ce constat qui perdure la
hausse des prix n'en finit plus de
grever le porte-monnaie des
consommateurs alimentation énergie
carburant les prix continuent
d'augmenter en cette rentrée une
inflation généralisée qui pousse chacun
à revoir ses habitudes de consommation
comme a pu le constater Rachel contensou
pour TV7 la chaîne du groupe sud-ouest
ce tourneré vers des marchés locaux et
modifier leurs habitudes alimentaires
c'est le choix qu'on fait ces Bordelet
croisés ce matin au marché des Capucins
en cause l'augmentation de 19 % de
l'alimentation en grande surface depuis
l'année dernière les prix sont deux fois
plus chers qu'ici en fait qu' au marcher
des Capucins donc tous les mois on vient
faire nos courses en début de mois pour
acheter la viande les poissons euh j'ai
fais plus attention avant je pouvais
manger je mangais trois fois par semaine
maintenant c'est une à deux fois par
semaine pour les poisson en plus de
l'alimentation l'essence n'a jamais été
aussi chère en 2023 là aussi des
sacrifices s'imposent de plus l'impôt
sur la taxe foncière a augmenté de 7,1 %
sur l'ensemble du territoire sans
oublier la hausse de l'électricité et du
gaz un véritable coup de Massu pour les
propriétaires alle c'est pas facile
maintenant parce que l'électricité elle
a dû prendre
je sais pas 20 % au moins enfin c'est
énorme les factures qui qui mont à une
vitesse et si ça continue comme ça
effectivement est-ce qu'on pourra garder
deux maisons on a actuellement deux
maisons une à la campagne est-ce qu'on
pourra garder les deux sur la retraite
mais bon on n pas des des revenu
extensible conséquence les bordelers
limitent également leurs dépenses sur
les sorties et loisirs je suis obligé de
me restreindre comme tout le monde donc
je rogne je ronge sur les extras tout ce
qui va être restaurant cinéma tous les à
côté aller boire des verres aller boire
des cafés un ralentissement global de la
hausse des prix est cependant prévu
d'ici la fin de l'année voilà et ce
contexte économique n'est pas sans
conséquence non plus sur le marché de
l'immobilier pour se loger aussi mieux
vaut être innovant près de Ren par
exemple une nouvelle offre permet de
vivre dans une maison comme à l'hôtel
une colocation réinventée où chaque
locataire bénéfici d'espace personnels
les précisions avec ce reportage de
Natacha Astor pour la rédaction de TVR
regardez
c'est le jour de l'installation pour
Maelan il occupe une chambre de 15 m
Carr dans ce coiving à Jan bienvenue
officiellement merci beaucoupas ton code
de chambre ouais je cherchais sur Ren
pour que ça corresponde plus à mes
études le charme et le la qualité de la
prestation ça m'a conquis direct quoi
cette Vitréenne d'origine a laissé de
côté son projet d'habiter seul à reen en
tombant par hasard sur l'annonce pour
570 € par mois elle dispose de toilettes
et d'une salle de bain privé le jan
c'est pas très loin de Rennes pas très
loin de vitrée non plus donc le lieu
était bien et puis le fait d'être à 8
c'est ça Vaah ça donner envie aussi
c'est vraiment une ambiance spéciale
quoi autre bonus un service de ménage
chaque semaine les h colivers de 25 à 42
ans se partage une maison de 270 m² avec
plusieurs espaces communs donc là c'est
le deuxième espace commun où on retrouve
donc un coin
coworking un petit espace salon qui va
justement
avec le bar pour pouvoir passer bah des
petites soirées sympathiques sur lequel
peut se retrouver la tireuse à bière un
dernier espace fermé dans lequel on a
voulu aménager une une salle au cinéma
le coliving c'est donc un mix entre la
colocation et l'hôtel colocation pour
les passes partager mais par contre on a
vraiment essayé de apporter beaucoup de
confort et de valeur pour gommer
justement tous les les zones de
frottement qui font en sorte que souvent
les les gens s'en vont parce qu'ils en
ont marre de composer avec soit des gens
qui font pas le ménage ou soit parce
qu'il on ont envie de partager leur
salle de bain leurs toilettes qui sont
aussi des espaces intimes coût total de
l'achat et de la rénovation dans le
centre de Janzé 1 demi million d'euros
Geoffrey souhaiterait développer
d'autres coliving a tour de
Rennes eux ont décidé de délaisser le
confort de leur maison pour
lesétroitestes d'un autocar dans l'au
unee famille s'est lancé dans un défi
insolite rénover un car pour en faire un
logement sur roue objectif vivre en se
déplaçant et en découvrant la France les
travaux devraient s'achever en décembre
une visite de chantier proposé par la
rédaction de Canal 32 dans
l'Aube d'ici quelques mois Maxime Carole
et leurs enfants eménageront dans cet
autocar de 12 m de long après avoir vécu
10 ans en iser le couple est revenu dans
l'aube pour commencer les travaux
objectif eménager le 1er décembre dans
cette maison itinérante de 30 m Carr
soit 8 mois de construction le projet il
a il a démarré vraiment pas longtemps
après la naissance de Clara après
grandes réflexion depuis depuis quelques
années on s'est dit c'est maintenant
maintenant ou jamais déjà d'être dehors
de de changer de coin assez souvent de
de bouger donc on a commencé avec un
camping-car et puis euh et puis après
par la suite on a aménagé notre scénique
où on est parti pareil en vacances
maximum on a fait 3 semaines et et après
en rentrant c'est vrai qu'on se on se
rendait compte que c'était vraiment la
vie qu'on voulait le couple a dégoté cet
autocar aux enchères pour 16000 € coût
total des travaux 60 5000 € ce qu'on
projette c'est être complètement
autonome en terme d'électricité
notamment en passant par l'installation
j'ai d'une petite centrale solaire
ensuite donc on va mettre un parc
batterie en conséquence pour pouvoir au
moins tenir entre 2 jours et demi voire
3 jours vraiment sans soleil et sur la
partie en eau on par sur une réserve
d'environ 1 m C d'eau qui nous
permettrait en gros de tenir 3 semaines
un mois en étant optimiste dans un
premier temps le couple prévoit de
rester en France pour adapter son
activité professionnelle Maxime dans
dans la création web Carole dans la
sophrologie pour les enfants et ben ça
sera donc école à la maison ça c'est ça
fait partie du moteur du projet aussi
c'est comme je disais d'être là pour nos
enfants et justement de pouvoir
s'impliquer pour eux on veut leur faire
aussi découvrir l'école classique et
avoir vraiment tous les éléments de
comparaison pourir dire on aiment bien
la vie que papa et maman nous offrent
aujourd'hui ou pas pour suivre leurs
aventures rendez-vous sur la page
facebook la famille à
bord impossible en ce mois de septembre
de ne pas transformer l'essai la Coupe
du monde de rugby en ce moment sont
plein partout en France et
particulièrement cela va de soi dans le
Sud-Ouest terre de l'auallie par
l'excellence la région abrite certains
lieux insolites comme cette brasserie
que vous voyez à l'écran sur place près
de Toulouse ce restaurant devenu presque
un musée affiche sur ses mur une
collection de plus de 1000 maillots rien
que ça écoutez à ce propos le gérant du
bar au micro de Nil ferrani pour notre
partenaire La Dépêche du Midi sur place
il y a des maillots plus connus comme le
maillot de Guitoun le maillot de
Dominici et puis après il y a des
maillots de de de de joueurs pas connus
mais mais mais quand ces joueurs de
temps en temps aussi reviennent voir le
la collection revient de manger un bout
au restaurant ils sont très émus voilà
et la passion du rugby bien sûr n'est
pas la panage de la seule région
toulousaine à Saint-Étienne aussi
l'effet Coupe du Monde se fait ressentir
dans les clubs locaux les enfants comme
vous le voyez sur ces images de TL7 la
chaîne de la Loire sont de plus en plus
nombreux à s'essayer au plaquages et aux
transformations image et propos
recueilli par Nathan Vacher regardez
quand j'ai vu l'équipe de France gagner
puis j'ai j'ai un copain et ben il m'a
donné envie il en faisait du coup bah
j'ai essayé j'ai bien aimé au début je
croyais vu que il y avait des placquages
je croyais c'était dangereux et tout
mais en vrai ça va c'est si tu si tu en
fais bien
c'est tu as pas mal c'est parce que
j'aimais bien et aussi parce que fallait
faire des plaquages faouait courir et vu
que fallait courir comme ma mère elle
voulait il fallait faire des plaquages
et que j' et que je voulais apprendre
les les placaages et ben ça m'a donné
envie de le faire voilà et comme tous
ces rugbyman en herbe on espère
évidemment voir les Bleus devenir
champion du monde le 28 octobre prochain
son sport à lui est fait de justesse et
de délicatesse partons à présent à la
rencontre de Sacha la roche un jeune
golfeur de 15 ans et qui est déjà en
course sur le circuit national adulte
une précocité rare qui ne surprend pas
néanmoins ce qui le côtoie depuis ses
débuts sur les greenes à l'âge de 4 ans
à sujet de Lucil pour télégranoble
inlassablement il frappe observe il
échoue il ajuste puis il frappe et se
régale d'un put après 10 tentatives et
plus Sacha gagne en précision plus il
impressionne à 15 ans seulement le
tulinois trace gaillardement sa route
parmi les tout meilleurs de sa catégorie
et même au-delà il a monté les échelons
petit à petit et puis là il commence à
intégrer donc le le monde adulte donc
quand on a son âge là il a il a 15 an et
donc on a toujours des compétitions un
petit peu chez les jeunes il commence à
faire des compétitions avec les grands
et il a intégré le carrément le
classement amateur français et il pointe
entre la 500e et la 600e place toute
catégorie au domaine de Charmeil à
SaintQuentin on s'en réjouit mais ce
n'est pas une surprise Sacha la roche
venait ici ha comme trois balles pour
prendre ses premiers cours et assouvir
une passion transmise par sa famille
c'est mon grand-père qui m'a initié au
golf quand j'avais 3 ans et demi 4 ans
et et le premier club avec lequel j'ai
tapé c un club qui m'avait fabriqué en
bois et je tapéis des balles dans mon
jardin avec et c'est comme ça que j'ai
commencé à taper mes premiè ball il est
très calme très sérieux et du coup c'est
des valeurs sur le parcours qui sont qui
sont importantes et si ces aptitudes
bonifie son potentiel le golf bonifie
sachat en retour il apprend il gagne en
gestion des émotions et renforce encore
sa confiance dans sa vie d'adolescent
serein et déterminé j'ai l'impression
d'être mieux organisé plus mature et
plus autonome sur ce que je fais parce
que je suis même pas en classe aménage
j'ai une vie complètement normale quoi
en terme de de cours et bah j'arrive à
me gérer à m'organiser tout va bien et
comme tout va pour le mieux au lycée
Sacha l roche veut poursuivre ses études
tout en progressant sur le green car le
golf lui apprend aussi à ne pas se voir
trop haut trop tôt tant que je suis bon
je continue si j'ai vraiment des choses
à faire bah
je ferai ça et et voilà des choses à
faire en se mesurant au meilleur
européens ce sera la prochaine étape
Sacha sera toujours prêt à saisir sa
chance au gré des surprises d'un
parcours que lui seul pourra
tracer tracer son chemin pour atteindre
son rêve c'est aussi la méthode employée
dans la Sarte par Hugo Cardon un jeune
skipper de 21 ans qui s'apprête à
embarquer dans quelques jours pour une
course en solitaire sur l'Atlantique des
sables d'olô à la Guadeloupe le jeune
homme est prêt pour le grand départ
rencontre avec Colin Ansel journaliste à
la rédaction de LMTV
Sart c'était en 2015 déjà sur LMTV Sart
bonjour je m'appelle Hugo je suis un
jeune skipper sur optimiste non je suis
passionné par la voile j'ai découvert
l'optimiste il y a 2 ans incroyable ça
fait bizarre de voir autant de temps
après aujourd'hui Hugo a 21 ans le 24
septembre il s'élancera des sables de
lonne pour la Mini transat direction les
Canaris d'abord puis la Guadeloupe c'est
un rêve pour tout marin traverser
l'Atlantique en solitaire et du coup la
Mini Transat c'est la première course en
gros c'est l'école de la course au large
mon bateau est prêt moi je suis prêt je
suis entraîné donc j'ai hâte de partir
pour me libérer l'esprit on va dire se
libérer l'esprit après des mois de
préparation il a fallu trouver entre 30
et 50000 € avec une préoccupation
majeure j'essaie de faire un projet 100
% stoi d'emmener tous les jeunes sartoi
leur montrer que c'est possible de
réussir dans la voie et notamment dans
la Course au Large alors c'est sûr en S
on est plus sur une terre de sport
automobile on va dire et du coup il y a
un engouement qui se crée aussi pour moi
aussi parce que je suis le plus jeune
marin là sur la mini transansat et et du
coup les entreprises souhaitent me
soutenir et moi je suis content et
heureux de représenter la Sart
représenter la Sart et peut-être même
dans des compétitions encore plus
prestigieuses et donc le but c'est de
continuer à en faire ma vie donc d'en
vivre donc c'est les entraînements les
courses et mon rêve ultime serait de
faire une route du Rome dans quelques on
va dire il ne nous reste plus qu'à lui
souhaiter bon vent
Hugo voilà bon vent et bonne chance à
lui pour cette belle traversée qui
débutera le 24 septembre elles sont
interdites depuis ce mois-ci les
trottinettes électriques ont délaissé
les trottoirs de la capitale une bonne
nouvelle diront certains un regret pour
d'autres mais que devient alors le parc
qui inondait encore récemment les rues
parisienne élément de réponse avec ce
sujet de Mélanie fort pour la chaîne
franilienne 20 minutes TV
[Musique]
5000 trottinettes rassemblé dans cet
entrepô après une longue vie dans les
rues de Paris depuis le 1er septembre
elles sont interdites en libre service
intramuros chacune d'entre elles sera
vérifiée en terme de sécurité elles
seront ensuite redéployé soit en
île-de-fance pour un tiers d'entre elles
sur les 5000 véhicules qu'on a et de
tiers partira à l'étranger en Allemagne
et en Pologne une sele alternative pour
exister sur le marché parisien tir mise
désormais tout sur ses vélos en libre
service
on reste cependant présent avec nos 5000
vélos à assistance électrique qui
restent dans la capitale et maintenant
c'est un véritable enjeu pour nous c'est
de nous assurer qu'il y a un report
modal c'estàd que nos usagers qui
utilisaient les trottinettes puissent
effectivement changer de mode de
transport pour aller vers les vélos un
report modal qui revet plusieurs formes
on va avoir un report qui va se faire à
la fois sur du transport en commun sur
du vélo et du du vélo en libre service
mais avec une limitation finalement de
la disponibilité de ces outil et un
report qui se fait sur l'achat cette
année la fin de la trottinette en libre
accès a bousculé les habitudes des
usagers dans cette boutique les clients
ont pris de l'avance et fintivement on a
quelques clients qui ont eux anticipé
n'ont pas attendu le 1er septembre sont
plutôt venus au mois de juin au mois de
juillet on nous a toujours amené de la
clientèle parce que le free floting même
s'il y a des gens qui sont de passage
des touristes et tout ça mais il y a
aussi une partie de la clientèle qui
l'utiliser pour faire des tests et donc
il pouent tester pendant un ou de jours
après se rend compte que le free floting
c'était bien mais que au quotidien ça
peut coûter vite cher une première
mondiale Paris la seule ville au monde à
avoir fait retirer les trottinettes en
libre
service vous le retrouverez bientôt sur
les étales de vos marchés préférés
pommes et poires sont pour l'heure
encore récolté dans les vergers et comme
redouté les alléas climatiques ont abîmé
certaines plantations un impact sur la
récolte annuelle que nous explique en
Haute Savoie lucarou pour la chaîne H8
Montblanc chaque fin d'été 16000 tonnes
de pommes estampié pay de sa voie sont
récoltés sur tout le territoire mais
cette année des épisodes violents de
grêle et d'orage ont eu raison de
certaines plantations comme c'est le cas
ici à usineins on voit les impacts de
grêes qui ont transpercé les fruits il
faut savoir qu'il y a eu beaucoup une
tornade une petite tornade qui est venue
en même temps et on voit que les
branches bah ils sont déchargé des
fruits les fruits sont tout tout pourris
donc voilà donc on se rend compte que
sans les filets paragell il y aurait
zéro récolte l'entreprise familiale
tisso est l'un des plus gros producteurs
de la région entre les différentes
parcelles les cueilleurs sont en pleine
récolte une récolte quelque peu
différente cette année comme il a le
triage comme ils sont grellé vois un peu
plus de un peu plus de travail en haut
de Savoie la récolte vient à peine de
débuter mais le bilan s'annonce déjà en
DEA des attentes à cause des intempéries
les vergers tisso estiment qu'ils ont
perdu près de 30 % de leur production
totale alors l'année est compliquée très
compliquée entre l'alternance le gel sur
certains secteurs là des gros épisodes
de grê donc il y a même des collègues
qui vont rien ramasser parce que c'est
c'est tout grellé donc non on a on a la
mal chance d'avoir ça fait plusieurs
années où c'est compliqué de de produire
dans dans nos départements on voit que
le changement climatique est de plus en
plus impactant pour nos productions les
pommes et poires de Savoie seront
récolté jusqu'à la fin du mois d'octobre
dans les verger de la région suite aux
récents alléas climatiques une
augmentation du prix de vente sera donc
prévoir pour les consommateurs allez
sans transition prenons la direction de
la Martinique dans ce journal où un
nouveau trésor de notre patrimoine vient
d'être choisi pour bénéficier des fonds
du Loto du patrimoine le moulin
hydroélectrique de la grande morne est
menacé d'effondrement bien qu'encore
partiellement en activité 90 ans
d'histoire sont ainsi en pass d'être
sauvés pour le plus grand bonheur des
habitants et des acteurs locaux un
reportage d'UL tidas pour via ATV
Martinique sous les coups de 11h les
gros mornis ont appris que le moulin
avec lequel ils ont grandi dans leur
commune a été choisi pour le loto du
patrimoine la rénovation à la clé il
faut l'encourager pour pouvoir continuer
il est très courageux c'est une bonne
chose mais je ne suis pas totalement au
courant mais pour le Gomon c'est bien
des années de dur labeur le propriétaire
a passé plusieurs mois à récolter des
fonds pour rénover le moulin la nouvelle
est donc tombée comme un cadeau du ciel
après avoir vécu autant d'années à
nourrir la population martiniicaaise
pourquoi ce moulin là est encore dans
cet état et aujourd'hui quand j'entends
le l'UTO du patrimoine la Fondation du
Patrimoine exercé et venir vers le
moulin pour dire et ben on est là pour
t'aider je me dis chapeau le moulin
hydroélectrique a 90 ans la structure
est vieillissante et continue pourtant à
produire des farines sans gluten à base
de manioc ou encore de fruits à pein une
activité que le propriétaire promeut
depuis plusieurs années il reçoit la
visite de personnalités notamment
politique extérieure sans soutien
financier et regrette le peu
d'engagement venant des élus martiniquet
après avoir à nombreuses
reprises cité leur comment dirais-je
désintéressement pour le patrimoine ça
m'a fait quand même un coup un coup au
cœur il y a une activité économique qui
est soutendue par le moulin ça déjà
c'est très intéressant c'est c'est la
mémoire de la Martinique pu ça date des
années 30 1933 il y a une il y a de
l'insertion il a je crois 7 jeunes en
insertion qui va réinsérer en tout cas
dans la vie économique dans le
circuit circuit économique normal
l'étiquet du Loto du patrimoine seront
vendus dans tous les points de vente de
jeux de Martinique le produit de leur
vente sera reversé à la mission
patrimoine piloté par Stéphane Bern puis
réparti parmi la centaine de sites
choisis cette année
favoriser l'insertion des plus jeunes
grâce à la culture et une exposition au
Musée des Beaux Arts voilà en quelques
mots cette belle initiative portée par
une association àimoge résultat un
travail photographique de qualité pour
évoquer les émotions face aux œuvres
d'art les précisions avec ce sujet
d'Alain druau pour la chaîne 7
alimog pousser la porte d'un musée n'est
pas toujours évident c'était le cas pour
une partie du groupe en contrat
d'engagement jeune jeunes en rupture un
dispositif d'accomp de jeunes de la
mobilité à l'emploi en passant par le
logement j'avais l'impression que
j'étais pas à ma place que ça me ça me
concernait pas avant le
groupe je je me suis jamais dit oui
j'allais venir toute seule ou avec Zoé
du coup mais depuis qu'on l'a fait en
groupe et on est venu plusieurs fois
c'est un membre de l'équipe des
conseillers en insertion professionnelle
qui a conçu ce projet comme une
exfiltration vers un milieu bénéfique
pour ce projet là c'était d'ouvrir
l'accès
bah la culture mais c'était aussi
reprendre confiance en soi se
remobiliser notamment face à l'emploi
face à la formation et donc l'idée elle
était un peu est un peu là et la culture
permet ça une initiative portée avec le
concours évident du musée mais également
de l'Association des Amis du Musée de
voir ces jeunes et de les accompagner
dans leur curiosité de répondre à leurs
questions c'est vraiment l'objectif des
Amis du Musée d'ouvrir ce merveilleux
édifice à tout le monde de les aider à
franchir orte de bonnes nouvelles sont à
partager à la fin de ce cycle avec des
emplois et de la formation en ligne dem1
ça m'a apporté beaucoup de beaucoup de
bien beaucoup de bien ça m'a fait du
bien de pouvoir sortir se stabiliser le
dispositif est réservé au moins de 26
ans et ouvert jusqu'à 29 pour les
candidats travailleurs handicapés sans
emploi ni
formation peu importe le motif votre
motivation ou la partie du corps choisi
le tatouage s'est répandu depuis
quelques années comme un véritable
phénomène de société un engouement ancré
dans la peau qui s'exposait il y a
quelques jours à mess à l'occasion d'un
salon international 200 artistes avaient
fait le déplacement et Emma fachchetti
et Jonathan vuchet étaient aussi
présents dans les allées de l'événement
regardé sur le bras la jambe le dos les
tatouages véritaable uvre d'art
fleurissent sur les corps des Mosellans
si certains sont déjà tatoués de la tête
au pied d'autres ont enfin décidé de
sauter le pas j'ai fait un premier
tatouage der l'oreille
donc avec le signe métaleux bah ça a
toujours été une envie de faire un
tatouage j'ai des lettres des lettrages
avec des phrases et je suis plutôt tout
ce qui est floral moi parce que c'était
un motif qui me plaisait et que j'avais
envie de d'en mettre sur mon corps parce
que ça habille le corps je trouve j'ai
des tatouage bah surtout tout le bras
avec le PEC l'autre bras j'ai trouvé le
côté artiste intéressant à la base
c'était le fait de d'avoir une création
qu'on puisse porter un peu comme un
tableau si autrefois le tatouage était
mal vu aujourd'hui un Français sur 5 est
tatoué soit 20 % de la population un
chiffre qui a doublé en 10 ans en terme
d'âge et de catégories sociopressionnell
c'est extrêmement varié je aussi une
clientèle qui est un peu plus âgé vu que
c'est des pièces qui coûtent assez cher
donc çaê des personnes qui travaillent
déjà qui ont un métier stable et qui
peuvent se permettre de de payer un
tatouage assez cher c'est vrai qu'il y a
beaucoup de gens maintenant qui sont
tatoué il y a quand même un effet
réseaux sociaux qui a fait que plus les
chaînes de télé réalité et tout bien
ancré dans la société le tatouage n'en a
pas fini de faire couler de
l'encre du tatouage professionnel et
contemporain aux usages historiques du
maquillage par les Amerindiens
transition toute trouvée pour cette fin
de journal alors que dans les vauges un
véritable camp autochtone s'est installé
le temps d'un weekend démonstration de
danse tour en calèche présentation des
chevaux et artisanat amer indien était
au rendez-vous pour le plaisir des
curieux et des passionnés un sujet
d'Aurélie Colombel et de Louis Houda
pour VUG
TV les chants et les danses des amers
indiens raisonnaient le weekend dernier
au Vermont non pas l'état américain même
si l'ambiance pourrait induire en erreur
mais sur les terrains communaux de le
puis et le Vermont des villages situés
au nord-est du département des vuges et
qui profitent rarement d'une telle
animation une trentaine de passionnés du
Nouveau Monde venus d'Alsace et
d'Allemagne ont planté tant typi
quelques jours l'occasion d'en apprendre
davantage sur cette culture à travers
son artisanat mais aussi les coutumes
cette façon de vivre qui a séduite le
local de l'étape à l'initiative de cette
rencontre Pierre loup représente la
nation comenche j'ai des tas de livres
sur sur les Amérindiens et on on se base
sur ça on veut montrer un peu leur
culture juste montrer la culture on on
n'est pas des Amérindiens mais c'est une
culture que j'adore c'est une culture
que j'aime et c'est une culture que j'ai
envie de de donner montrer aux gens
c'est donc un voyage dans le temps au
tatanakamp le camp des bisons on y vit
comme 200 ans en arrière trappeurs
colons indiens réunis pour l'occasion
présentent leurs costumes et leur
maquillage dans les cheveux des
guerriers les plus braves des plumes les
anciens mènent la danse et guident les
tribus par leur sagesse et leur
connaissance je pense que les
Amérindiens ce sont les premiers
écologistes de l'histoire tout le monde
commence à prendre conscience de notre
terre en avait conscience il y a très
longtemps
et souvent on l'entend parmi les les
dictons parmi les proverbes Amérindiens
les paroles de SAG toutes nous
rappellent à quel point la Terre Mère
est importante le pH Ouest a pris ses
marques entre les sapins lors de cette
deuxè édition le camp a plus que doublé
rendez-vous est déjà annoncé au beau
jour l'an prochain avec un rassemblement
qui pourrait être de plus grande
ampleur voilà c'est la fin de cette
édition merci à vous de nous avoir suivi
on se retrouve très vite pour une
nouvelle édition du Grand JIT des
territoires au revoir à
[Musique]
tous